new yorker writer jane mayer
gave an interesting interview to npr's
terry gross
a few days ago and the topic was whether
donald trump might end up being the
first president to ever be criminally
charged now as i've said before
i maintain and believe that donald trump
will
never see the inside of a prison cell
some people write to me and they tell me
i'm wrong well i mean we can't say i'm
wrong yet it hasn't happened yet
some people write to me and say david
when you say that it makes it less
likely trump will go to prison i don't
think me saying it makes it any less
likely
but the fact that i don't think trump
will ever see the inside of a prison
cell doesn't mean he won't be charged
and as jane mayer points out in this
interview with npr which you can find
online
there are a number of viable paths to
donald trump ending up with criminal
charges against him being the first
president to have such charges against
him
right now we know of two possible
criminal charges
investigations with possible criminal
charges coming the first is the
investigation
in georgia over donald trump's now known
multiple phone calls trying to get the
election results changed
in the 2020 georgia presidential
election the second one
and the one that actually predates the
georgia probe is the one led by
manhattan district attorney cyrus vance
which is looking at trump's financial
practices and in that one
tax banking insurance fraud all on the
table
and that's the one where uh they finally
got a decision from the supreme court
that indeed trump's financial records
must be turned over and they have been
so now cyrus vance has those records now
as i've said before
the most likely scenario is some kind of
financial charges
probably against others at the trump
organization
but still it's possible donald trump
could be criminally charged in
that investigation jane mayer addresses
many of the important questions for
example terry gross
asks her whether even if trump committed
crimes
we should just move on because trump is
gone and jane mayer points out
listen it's true that lots of the
countries
that charge former leaders with crimes
are not necessarily the countries we're
trying to emulate but
she argues that if the crimes trump
committed aren't even related to the
presidency
these are business crimes for example
what reason is there not to pursue them
pursue them and this is an important
point
we know that every president makes
decisions that lead to deaths
but we don't charge presidents in those
cases because it would make being
president impossible i'm not saying
that i'm against war crimes charges
that's not at all what i'm saying but
every time you cut aid or shift military
resources
send troops into war change some welfare
program do a drone strike
every presidency leads to civilian
deaths some of which could have been
avoided right or wrong
u.s presidents don't get charged with
that stuff and we can have a debate
about that but that's not what we're
talking about here
if we find out trump was laundering
money through his business
who cares if he was president for a
four-year period
it's unrelated to him being president
and there shouldn't be a culture of
impunity as jane mayer
correctly points out the possible
financial crimes
and fraud in new york are significant
taking tax deductions on things that
aren't tax deductible to the tune of
millions of dollars
including even some of those hush money
payments that donald trump made
exaggerating or diminishing the claimed
value of real estate
to manipulate lenders and taxation
authorities to his benefit
there's a very long list here and these
are crimes in the state of new york
on the tail end of this the question of
prison comes up
are the things being investigated
theoretically punishable by prison time
yes would trump get prison time
even if found guilty it's possible
would he serve it i can't imagine jane
mayer says in the interview
she believes trump would flee the
country if he actually were
sentenced to prison time the truth is i
don't think that's very likely
but we're in such unprecedented
territory that it's very difficult to
predict
my sense is the most likely scenario is
there's no prison time
and trump doesn't have to flee i still
believe that's the most
obvious and logical scenario the
importance to me of criminally charging
trump
isn't to put him in prison it's twofold
first it's to show that a president
isn't above the law
and maybe that will prevent another
president from being as corrupt and
criminal as donald trump
maybe that's naive but that's one
important element of this
secondly as a very practical matter if
there are criminal charges against
donald trump
it could just keep him too busy to even
think about running again in 2024 and
that would be a very good thing
we'll have more coverage of this on the
david pakman show instagram
you can follow us there at david pakman
show follow me on instagram at
david.pacman if you want to see
me um uh what would be the right word
that's not really accosted
smothered by a dog that doesn't
understand the concept of personal space
follow me on instagram at david.pakman
one of our sponsors is privacy.com
they're giving you five dollars when you
sign up for
their completely free service at
privacy.com
pacman i've been using privacy for a
little over a year now you've heard me
talk about it before
it's a lifesaver and here's how it works
takes just a couple of minutes to set up
anytime you buy something online or on
the phone
instead of actually using your real
credit card number
the privacy app and the browser plug-in
let you give each company
a randomized virtual credit card number
that you create out of thin air it'll
even auto fill the card number with one
click
and the payment is taken out of your
checking account
without the merchant ever knowing your
real information so this allows you to
keep
your banking information secure but also
to take control of your finances you can
create
up to 12 of these virtual credit cards a
month you can set
spending limits you can freeze them you
can delete them anytime you want so when
you do this
it means you're not going to be charged
when you don't want to be
because you can destroy the virtual card
number
right after using it which for instance
i love using free trials because i know
i won't be charged when the trial is
over
if i use a virtual credit card number
you're keeping your identity private
by not telling companies who you are
you're keeping your bank or
credit card info protected against data
breaches and identity theft
and it's free and like i said you'll get
five dollars
to spend when you sign up at privacy.com
slash pacman